on le pensait enterré voilà qu'il refait
surface l'accord très critiquée de libre
échange avec le mercosur
il porte sur les relations commerciales
entre l'union européenne et les pays du
cône sud argentine brésil uruguay et
paraguay
il autoriserait ces derniers à exporter
notamment 99 milles tonnes de viande
bovine 180 mille tonnes de volailles en
europe avec des droits de douane réduits
ou nuls
quand il est vrai qu'on en manque en
france cet accord élaboré depuis plus de
vingt ans et qui n'a pas encore été
ratifiée porterait un coup fatal à nos
éleveurs mais il provoquerait aussi une
forte accélération de la déforestation
dans les pays d'amérique du sud pour
nourrir le bétail
la forêt amazonienne a déjà perdu 8 % de
sa surface en 18 ans en majeure partie à
cause de l'élevage
autre sujet d'inquiétude le fait que la
viande de ces pays ne soient pas
soumises aux mêmes normes sociales
sanitaires et environnementales que
celle produite en europe en 2019 les
protestations tribune manifestation
avait foisonner pour dénoncer cette
concurrence déloyale en août 2019 alors
que l'amazone y brûler emmanuel macron
avait durci le ton envers le président
brésilien jaillir ball sonar où il avait
alors refusé de signer les accords oui
mais avec la doctrine du en même temps
un refus c'est aussi une autorisation et
mediapart vient de découvrir un document
du ministère du commerce extérieur
examinant des pistes pour rétablir le
mercosur il liste des garanties à
obtenir des pays du sud
concernant l'environnement et les normes
l'europe estime qu'elle a à gagner à
exporter des voitures tandis que les
pays de la corne ou vente des produits
agricoles
ainsi la france fait face à la pression
de l'union européenne la présidence
portugaise du conseil de l'union
insistant pour que cet accord soit
ratifié de nombreux députés européens et
personnalités politiques sont
scandalisés
la france a refusé de signer disait la
ministre aujourd'hui les masques tombent
d'après médiapart le gouvernement
planche pour lever son veto sur l'accord
macron s'accommode donc d'un accord avec
golden arrow qui met le feu à la masoni
eva contre nos valeurs
après avoir autorisé la commission de
bruxelles a signé le traité mercosur
permettant l'importation de boeuf aux
hormones pu avoir fait semblant de s'y
opposer
emmanuel macron se prépare finalement à
libéraliser les importations de viande
qui vont tuer nos éleveurs
franck riester ministre délégué au
commerce extérieur réagi à la découverte
de médiapart
non notre position est très claire le
gouvernement ne soutient pas le projet
d'accord eux mais reconnurent en l'état
tout est dans le en l'état mais en même
temps si l'on ajoute quelque chose non
contraignante ça peut passer
car le ministre avoue bien mené un
travail en concertation avec les acteurs
concernés en france et dans l'union
européenne
mais est il réaliste d'espérer négocier
de telles clauses
écoutons l'avis de bruno dufayet
président de la fédération nationale
bovine
il ya aussi toute la compatibilité de ce
discours avec le droit du commerce et
des droits de l' omc
il ya quand vous voyez qu'en france on a
mis un article dans le cadre de la loi
j'ai un article c'est l'article 44 qui
normalement interdit la
commercialisation de produits ne
respectant pas nos normes
la france n'arrive même pas à mettre en
application sur son territoire cet
article là et on voudrait nous expliquer
qu'on pourrait demain arrivé à imposer
des clauses dans un accord dans un
accord de libre échange entre l'europe
et le mercosur donc là aussi on sait que
voilà c'est de l'enfumage c'est pas
possible
quel est l'intérêt d'aller nous mettre
en concurrence avec ces pays là une
concurrence complètement déloyale on
n'arriverait pas résisté face à 7 face à
cette arrivée de massifs de viande
venant de partout sur la planète qui est
donc voilà là aussi quelle est la
logique pris en tenaille entre les
agriculteurs les ong environnementales
les protecteurs de la souveraineté
alimentaire d'une part et les pays
membres d'autre part emmanuel macron
aura-t-il le courage de continuer à
poser son veto contre le mercosur
rien n'est moins sûr